bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors c'est pas vraiment
une surprise que la hongrie et la
pologne saisisse la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
mais tout d'abord pourquoi bourse elle
tenait tant à ce mécanisme à ce
dispositif
bruxelles l économie européenne va
extrêmement mal on était déjà avant même
la crise due cori d' une des zones avec
la plus faible
le plus faible taux de croissance du
monde l'économie était déjà très mal en
point avant la prise du comider mais non
nous avons vu que quasiment un an après
le déclenchement de ce virus sur le sol
européen que de nombreuses personnes
sont au chômage
de nombreuses personnes soit ce rapport
aux abois et que beaucoup de personnes
attendent des réponses de la part de
leur politique que la plupart des
politiques en france en allemagne en
espagne n'ont pas forcément les moyens
des politiques qui ont été menées
tout le monde se retourne vers l'union
européenne comme le la planche de salut
pour sauver les nations européennes qui
sont rentrés dans une phase de récession
et qui ont besoin d'un coup de pouce
puisque un peu poussé besoin d'une corne
end relancer leur économie
c'est pour ça que l'union européenne
lance un aujourd'hui comme le sauveur
des nations européennes elle fasse avec
musicaux alors aujourd'hui quelle peut
être la décision de la cour quels sont
les scénarios envisageables
les plusieurs scénarios je pense que
c'est important de reparler du point
principal sert qu'on est rentré
aujourd'hui dans une logique ou
bruxelles serait capable décider qui
respecte l'état de droit ou pas
normalement l'union européenne est une
union union de nations souveraines
on se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'on va
l'union européenne c'est là que les
états unis d'europe comme on l'a les
états unis d'amérique et que la pologne
la hongrie illégalement la france ou
l'espagne
elle bien sont des états comme le sens
états unis le wyoming la californie et
que si un gouvernement fédéral qui est
au dessus de tout ça il peut décider qui
a le droit ou pas de recevoir des
subventions des aides c'est un point
très important qui est je pense que
beaucoup de de pro européens n'ont pas
tout à fait compris ces règles de
l'union européenne quelles sont les
issues
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas trop il faut
déjà savoir que l'instruction de ces
plaintes peuvent durer un à deux ans
comme ça à prendre beaucoup de temps
est-ce que l'union européenne osera
aller jusqu'à exclure des pays qui ne
respectent pas le dise que le athleta
d'autres parce qu'ils vont voir ce que
doit posséder fille comme état de droit
ça m'étonnerait en revanche le mécanisme
actuel de distribution de l'aide ont
paru plus de 700 milliards et abus et un
budget de 2021 2022 le de 1000 milliards
d'euros est bloqué du coup il va y avoir
une très grande pression et sur
bruxelles et sur ces pays pour essayer
de trouver un consensus
sachant que pour l'instant on a vu ces
dernières années la pologne et lambris
maintenez la position et donc du coup
est ce que l'union européenne s'apprête
à l'est à l'éclatement pour montrer ce
que c'est que l'état de droit et cédric
sur deux pays dont la pologne qui était
un des meilleurs élèves de l'union
européenne ces dernières années je le
pense pas alors on a eu un budget
européen arraché au forceps avec
l'utilisation de veto et là on le voit
tout de suite avec astrazeneca des pays
européens qui continuent d'utiliser le
vaccin d'autres qui préfèrent le
suspendre certains diront que c'est ça
la démocratie
d'autres que c'est un peu le reflet
d'une europe qui n'est pas fondée quel
est votre avis votre analyse c'est que
l'union européenne ait perdu dans son
immensité et elle est perdue et ne sait
plus où sont les priorités elle ne sait
pas les gérer et elle est tiraillée
entre sa volonté ferme de vouloir tout
régenter
et la réalité c'est l'incapacité cayla
de se donner les moyens pour mener cette
politique et elle dit qu'il veut sauver
les européens que la voir un plan de
relance et qu'il faut développer des
vaccins
or beaucoup de pays européens n'ont pas
de vaccin aujourd'hui l'union européenne
se s'engage à donner des vaccins à des
pays qui ne sont pas membres de l'union
européenne ont levé dans le partenariat
oriental à l'azerbaïdjan à la halla
halla gerville l'union européenne veut
donner des vaccins et des pays européens
n'ont pas aujourd'hui donc elle n'est
pas capable parce que l'union européenne
par les moyens de sa politique ça c'est
la réalité et après les politiques
locaux font face à la réalité des
personnes qui veulent des solutions des
personnes qui veulent vite retrouver la
vie devant la normalité des personnes
certaines que les vaccins long par
accident du coup aller les pays les
régions sont obligés de s'organiser
mais se rendre compte cette inefficacité
de l'union européenne et le problème est
que bruxelles ne me sens pas content
cette situation et continue de se rendre
un parangon de vertu de dicter à
d'autres ps et à qui est-ce qui respecte
ou par l'état de droit tout en se
rendant pas compte que ce qu'il a montée
elle même aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas
à de nombreuses failles et il espère de
plus en plus de repères qui se demande à
quoi sert l'union européenne est ce que
finalement on n'a pas un peu les pays
fondateurs de noeux et puis les autres
oui il ya un peu de ça il ya un peu de
ça ça va un peu au-delà c'est faut pas
oublier que derrière les pays fondateurs
vous aviez quand même les états unis
d'amérique et ter et un plan bien précis
pour l'europe quand la deuxième guerre
s'est terminée que washington tire
encore beaucoup plus d'officiels qu'on
croit aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque mais on
voit qu'il n'ya pas moyen en déployer et
voir lui mieux la brussels donner des
leurs ait des règles sur l'état de droit
c'est ridicule un jour de juste à rennes
a rappelé le brussels a souligné la
révolte du maiden en ukraine qui a
renversé un président démocratiquement
élu que l'union européenne a reconnu
comme président du venezuela le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
était même pas élu président du
venezuela dont l'union européenne ne
respect pas l'état de droit dans des
pays étrangers et veut dire à certains
pays voici ce que c'est que l'état de
droit ce n'est pas logique et donc du
coup ces pays là notamment aux deux pays
de l'est mais aussi des pays comme
l'italie se pose la question qu'est ce
que c'est que cette union européenne qui
nous apporte beaucoup de contraintes et
pas beaucoup de solutions et à la fin on
retrouve en effet espèce d'esprit
libéral a soumis aux états unis autour
de laurent de six mois la fin mois la
plus la grande bretagne était opaque et
partent aujourd'hui mais qui est dans ce
même le faire en cas d'erreur
géographique
ça c'est peut-être l'esprit très libéral
de l'union européenne comprend plus qui
prend deux pas du tout dans les pays
l'est et qui ont de moins en moins dans
les pays de l'ouest
nicolas mirkovic merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste politique merci à vous